welcome back finley toyota the sponsor
of this next segment has a top-notch
service department john barr had us come
down to take a look at the service area
in one very special vehicle
[Music]
hey john how's it going i'm doing great
i had to get you down there jc i've got
a surprise here i know you're a huge
back to the future fan oh i got
something special here what do you got
behind you a delorean no something even
better
[Music]
it's the toyota from back to the future
this is marty mcfly's toyota sr5 from
the movie john this is incredible i knew
you'd love it you know the secret to
having a vehicle like this is surface
yeah exactly that's true yeah it's the
only way to kind of keep it up because
obviously 35 36 years old but i got the
guy to help you
douglas come over and meet jc hey doug
see you buddy good to see you man all
right let's show me around the service
department doug the first thing i notice
walking back here is the size how big is
the facility yeah we're one of the
largest dealerships in the country so we
have 100 service stalls and about 70
technicians now what's this guy what's
your technician chris working on here uh
looks today like he's actually just
doing some basic maintenance we're
replacing spark plugs today and that's
what you do here right it doesn't matter
the make or model you service all
vehicles yeah we'll work on all makes
and models um even though we're a toyota
dealership but we'll do anything from
your basic you know maintenance the tire
replacement all the way up to an engine
replacement looks like someone's here
was working on some tires changing out
some tires here yeah yeah we're probably
just doing a tire rotation on this one
that's perfect that's great now you do
so you service all vehicles and how many
technicians do you have working back
here we have 70 technicians 70
technicians if you need your car service
there's going to be someone here at
finley toyota that's going to take care
of it yeah we welcome walk-ins um
obviously you can schedule an
appointment but we're staffed enough to
where we can take you in any time you
want to come in i noticed these are all
over the shop what does this say you got
a chain here what's this thing up here
uh this is actually an exhaust fan so
basically when the technicians are
working on the cars and they're running
in their bay they hook them to the
exhaust so we can keep the air in here
clean connected oh my gosh you take care
of your people i i love that now if
someone does get their vehicle service
do you offer rental programs um so we
have we give complimentary lift rides to
and from if we need to we do have a
rental department here if somebody wants
to rent a car we can do that and we also
offer a pickup and delivery service also
if people don't have the time to make it
down we saw now this is an older uh
toyota here we have the back to the
future truck how important is it to stay
on top of service of your vehicle yeah i
mean if you want the car to run a long
time maintenance is the key so as long
as you can keep up on the maintenance as
you can see in the shop we have a lot of
cars that that have quite a bit of age
on them but they're still running and
that's because people don't you know do
the maintenance that they need they see
on top of things you're certified
pre-owned vehicles how many checks do
they go through back here before we put
them out on the lot so every certified
toyota that we have goes through 160
point inspection
wow you see you look look over
everything what do we got here doing
some brake work back here yeah it looks
like that's more uh replacing the rear
brakes
brake's right here brakes are right here
i know my stuff thank you i appreciate
it buddy appreciate you man thank you
very much all right john i'm ready for
my test drive what road are we taking
roads
where we're going we don't need roads
thank you to findley toyota for
sponsoring this segment they're located
in henderson and you can call them at
702-566-2596 find them online at
findlaytoyota.com